like you had a really unique childhood
and i know that
that's part of what you wrote about in
your book um
but i mean can you can you can do you
have perspective now
of kind of what that was like and the
the good that you were able to extract
from it and then also the things that
maybe needed some reprogramming
or new perception for sure yeah i mean
i definitely had an unconventional
upbringing for sure
um you know youngest of five kids
growing up in jersey yes my father was a
doctor and
my mom was this very eccentric
chef which is a huge part of why i cook
i mean she inspired me so much in the
kitchen and
you know watching her you know working
on her
tart flambe at two o'clock in the
morning and i'm like following her
around the kitchen because that's the
only time i could hang out with her
because she was not
your typical mom you know what i mean
like i've never been told to do my
homework i've never
been given a rule in my life and and i
think because of that
i i was like really responsible kid
because i had nothing to rebel against
like all my friends were rebelling and
doing all this stuff because their
parents were so many rules on them and i
was like
i i don't have anything to rebellion
says my mom was just
you know a very eccentric person and my
father
had the most amount of cases in two
hospitals which was like unheard of so
all he did was work
but yeah my mom was a huge influence on
me in the kitchen
and you know it's interesting because
you know you asked have i been able to
kind of
reflect on it or what's my viewpoint of
it now the thing that's really
interesting
is until i had kids
i had never fully dissected
my upbringing you know what i mean um
well really looked at it like i i have
so many justifications of things that
were
like not okay growing up just like
period
like not cool and i'm also not the type
of person who blames i'm just like i
always try to look at
okay so how did i help cause this and
what can i
take from this so this doesn't happen
again that's so responsible
well i try i mean i try um and
i think because i was on my own at such
a young age like i left my house when i
was 15 and i've been on my own since
then but
wow when i had kids especially
my first child being a girl when i first
had my daughter
it was you know i was i had crazy
postpartum anxiety
first of all didn't even know what that
was because when you
i didn't know anything about motherhood
so when i you know the only thing that i
basically heard about postpartum
anything
was like you always hear about
postpartum depression because that's
like in the
you know that's uh in the verbiage of
things that mothers can suffer from and
i didn't have any of that you know what
i mean but i had this
this overwhelming anxiety
to protect this baby and
you know i was living in the lower east
side and
any time like a siren would go up the
street i would be i would think that i
couldn't protect her i would think it
was like
an attack on my family i was having
panic attacks and all this stuff
and that is not my personality like that
is so
i really do pride myself on being like
the rock of gibraltar i really do like
that's why i love directing i love
having
a ton of responsibility and pressure
pressure and stress
and i'm like i i tend to do pretty well
in those kinds of environments like
super high pressure type stuff i um
and and i think that is one of the
reasons why i love directing it's one of
the reasons why i love high stakes poker
and i used to be like obsessed with poke
and all this like you know
i mean with with your career you must be
the same way
well i seek out discomfort i've found
that since i retired
i didn't feel like i used to be very
adventurous and then since i've retired
now i've like jumped out of helicopters
gone bungee jumping
you know i learned how to ski and
snowboard and wake surf
and like things that i wouldn't have
otherwise done so i and or
saying yes to interviews or people or
situations
and i realize that what i really like to
do is i really like to put myself in an
uncomfortable situation
to push sort of the threshold and widen
it like i like to get into that like
oh god should i do this can i do this to
prove to myself that i can
i don't know if that you can relate to
that but i just like to be uncomfortable
i can absolutely relate to that and i
used to put myself in situations like
that as well i totally get it
and to a point where i was like
you know when i was about to have my my
first kid i was out with a friend of
mine who was fully fully like
about to have her baby and i was still
like only halfway through
um like pregnancy and i'm like what is
the hardest thing like what should i
look out for because no one talks about
this stuff that's really hard
and she was like oh no she just had her
baby she just had her baby
and she was like it's it feels like your
heart
is outside of your body and you're
trying to make sure that nothing hurts
this thing and she's like and it's just
like your heart is outside walking
around your body
and she's like it's the most stressful
thing you'll ever experience and i'm
like
i'm okay with stress like i think i'm
gonna be okay no
no the universe was like laura let me
just show you
exactly for all the reasons we just said
like we put ourselves in these
uncomfortable situations and all this
stuff yeah nothing
prepared me for here
giving birth hearing that first squawk
of my daughter just
ripped through my entire being and i
woke up
at like a mother like i i everything you
could possibly imagine like i i
like in that moment like i woke up and
something inside of me woke up and
and i was so scared that i couldn't
protect her
and so in those moments you innately go
back to what you know
so i innately would fall back on okay so
how i was raised so it was go back to
work
right exactly it was the first time i
i like looked at how my mother raised me
you know what i mean because in that
moment of like anxiety you know what
you're doing
you go right to what you know it's like
um you know professional athletes and
you know you can speak to some cars and
everything which by the way is
incredible
um i watched you all the time when i
lived in england racing on that 70s show
i mean i was so grateful there was a
cool show on because there's in england
i'm sure you've probably spent time
there doing something yeah yeah yeah
yeah for sure
not a lot of channels and i was like oh
my god i'm so grateful there's like a
cool show
i've been a fan for a long time we
actually i think we met
very briefly like literally 20 years ago
because i went to a race i did this race
and you were there and of course you
i mean you were i think one of the only
yeah female uh race card at the time you
were just
paved the way for it unbelievable what
you did
um and i remember meeting you then and
being like oh my god this woman is just
a complete badass
takes one to no one maybe thank you
but um but i do remember that that
experience of being at a race and
singing there and it was very inspiring
and you were just
so thank you oh god um it's interesting
so when i looked back at how i was
raised
uh it was the first time i was like wow
that's actually
some of that stuff is not cool some of
that stuff is i hear you
not okay and it was the first time i
really had to
come face to face with that so in terms
of what you're asking
of you know kind of my viewpoint on it
now is
i like to look at it and say okay great
i can now choose what i'm going to pass
on to my kids
and what to leave behind